empecemos recordando que no es la
primera vez que el gobierno de Colombia
y la guerrilla del Ln se sientan a
negociar sin embargo sí que es la
primera vez que El Ejecutivo colombiano
es de izquierdas en que puede suponer
esto una diferencia
muy buenas noches a todos Bueno en este
sentido quizás haya alguna atención en
la mesa en la medida en que gran parte
de las banderas del Ln quedarían
recogidas dentro de la propuesta de
gobierno del presidente Petro eso les
quita peso político y deslegitima aún
más las causas que ellos han egredo para
seguir alzados en armas en contra del
Estado colombiano
Como por ejemplo nos podría dar algunos
ejemplos sobre estas causas bueno ellos
siempre hablaron pues primero de la toma
del poder nacional en el marco de la
guerra fría la influencia de la
revolución cubana un estado Injusto en
el cual
las vías democráticas estaban cerradas
para el acceso al poder y en este
sentido lo que ha demostrado el
presidente Petro es que esta narrativa
queda sin piso porque él hace 30 años
dejó las armas también en el marco un
proceso de negociación de fin de
conflicto con la media 19 y hoy es el
presidente de la república después de
haber participado en cuatro elecciones
presidenciales claro Precisamente en
relación a lo que usted comenta no la
delegación del gobierno colombiano está
liderada por OTI Patiño fundador de la
guerrilla del m-19 de la que como usted
bien decía también fue Miembro el
presidente Gustavo Petro pero
precisamente Cómo puede influir la
figura de Patiño en los diálogos no este
pasado es guerrillero
pues lo que se espera es que es alguien
que conoce digamos la vida guerrillera
por dentro también tuvo la utopía
Revolucionaria como Horizonte y en ese
sentido Pero yo que el lenguaje O tal
vez se desactivan un poco las tensiones
que podrían presentarse en la mesa
también es novedoso que junto a OTI
Patiño va a estar un representante del
gremio de los ganaderos fedegán cuyo
nombramiento como negociador se hizo
hace unos pocos días en la ciudad de
Barranquilla y él le daría voz en la
práctica un agente regionales
históricamente han sido muy resistentes
a la implementación de acuerdo que se
logran en mesas de negociación nacional
porque los intereses de las élites
locales no son tenidas en cuenta
entonces Esto va a poner un escenario
muy interesante porque va a haber
negociaciones dentro del equipo
negociador pero también negociaciones
con la contraparte guerrillera